c'est pourquoi monsieur l'agent je suis
ici pour vous informer d'un crime
horrible et de quel crime horrible il
s'agit au maire jean raconte n'importe
comment
petit rappel historique tout a commencé
quand le joker et moi on s'est séparés
par consentement mutuel
évidemment peu de temps après je suis
sur pied prête à éveiller la divinité
féroce qui sommeille en moi
maintenant que j'ai coupé les ponts avec
monsieur j je m'apprête à découvrir que
plein de gens veulent ma mort alors est
en haut de la ligue il ya nuit mais
elles se trouvent
que je ne suis pas la seule me fagot tam
qui a besoin de s'émanciper
il veut notre peau attend la gamine la
dépouiller soient fut l'a trahi
toi t'as but et son meilleur pote quoi
alors toi t'es trop cool lumière était
assez comme pour avoir mené une enquête
contre lui
alors si on veut pas tout sourire dans
des souffrances abjecte faut qu'on se la
joue collectif
d'accord
[Musique]
vu sous l'angle de thérapeutique la
vengeance importe rarement la catharsis
dont on a besoin
certes alors on est pris du retard
bomber le torse
oh
[Musique]
[ __ ] basit est mienne dans une
baignoire je l'appelle brousse en
l'honneur de wayne de beau gosse